they retired number 12 in seattle for
the fans that's my segue to the fact
that russell wilson is still making news
but not because of anything he's said or
done
cam jordan appearing on espn's get up
this morning talking about the
possibility of russell wilson joining
the saints and what it would mean for
the saints to have number three unless
it's been retired and then they'd have
to unretire it for him to wear number
three here's cam jordan
the last couple years you've looked at
our defense we've turned the page in our
defense that have made us more
complimentary towards our team as a
whole
and the one thing we had been lacking
you know prior to the last couple years
was our defense now if you give us a guy
like russell wilson because drew has
retired because he has deemed it so fit
i would take russia wilson in a
heartbeat
that's seeing that's it
i think i think we've always been poor
do you win the super bowl so
absolutely
but that's that's my that's my vision
year and you're waiting on
okay no i like that let's go to say it
cam
no greenie don't let him off the hook
cham if you get russell wilson do you
have a super bowl ring
i believe if russell wilson plays the
way he did at the beginning of last
season and he plays that way throughout
the whole season absolutely
i
i think cam jordan just said that
russell wilson stunk
in the latter part of last season he did
because the qualification is he's got to
play like he did back in it when it was
let ross cook and he's never gotten an
mvp vote he's going to get all of them
this year yeah there's there's a couple
of qualifications there one being
russell's got to play like he did early
last season and second cam's head i
always have the mindset that we're gonna
win the super bowl so whoever the
quarterback is he's gonna go into the
season thinking they're gonna win the
super bowl so they were trying their
damn just to get him to make some broad
proclamation and he did
but there clearly were a couple of
caveats shireen
well yeah and you know i think the
seahawks frankly would have been super
bowl contenders if russ had played like
he did in the first seven games they
were six and one 26 touchdowns six
interceptions
120.8 passer rating in those last nine
games not so much 14 touchdowns seven
interceptions
91.8 rating and then we know what
happened in the postseason they lost the
rams in the first round 11 and 27 174
yards two touchdowns an interception and
the five sacks let's not forget that he
wasn't good at the end of the season the
seahawks would have been a
super bowl contender if russ had played
like he did the first seven games but he
didn't and the seahawks weren't so
you know the saints yearly are a super
bowl contender they have been since sean
payton got there whoever they have at
quarterback i think we're still going to
think of them as a super bowl contender
i think russell wilson would be their
best option depending on what they have
to give up for him because if you
mortgage your future form if you have to
trade a guy like cam jordan and several
other guys and a bunch of draft picks i
mean i guess it would be sort of like
the ricky williams acquisition right
when they traded their entire draft for
for ricky williams sort of like that and
we know what happened to the saints then
so you know i more expect jameis one
center taysom hill to be the quarterback
i know cam jordan previously has said he
thinks that jameis winston is going to
be their quarterback unsigned right now
so we'll see how that plays out but i
don't expect russell wilson to be their
quarterback and i still expect the st
saints to go into next season as a
contender mike
i think it would count as irony and
again i never quite know when that term
is being properly used thanks to that
song from the 90s but i think it would
be irony if cam jordan were actually
traded to the seahawks as part of the
transaction that brought russell wilson
to the new orleans saints and there was
a recent tweet from cam jordan where
there were some rumors making the rounds
on social media that he reacted to
acknowledging that he's not interested
in being part of the trade package and
he wants to
me getting trained and then rumors
better state rumors a man goes on a bus
tour with his family for two weeks and
russ becomes available on social media
rumors got my name in a pot stop it
that's great um but but hey i've said
all along the saints should call the
seahawks and say just tell us who you
want just tell us who you want and we'll
we'll we'll see what you'll want and
we'll see if we can work it out because
they got to cut so much cap space
that
the seahawks could do them a favor by
trading russell wilson to them so they
could unload guys rather than cutting
them loose and getting nothing at least
you can say these guys were part of the
package that we used to get russell
wilson
yeah they certainly are a team that
should make a call mike and at least ask
the seahawks what it would take to get
russell wilson if you're told no maybe
you come back and say all right well
here's what we would offer if indeed
russell wilson went on the trading block
at some point so keep us in mind if that
happens but he would certainly upgrade
them at the quarterback position no
question about that i think we all agree
with that it just depends on what kind
of team they can put around them but we
don't know what kind of team they're
going to be able to put around taysom
hill or jameis winston or whatever for
that matter with their with their cap
problems right now
all right uh i think we've covered
plenty of ground here in this opening
segment by the way the oddsmakers not
moved by the talk of russell wilson
being traded seattle minus 1250 that
means you got to bet 1250 to win a mere
hundred seattle the overwhelming
favorite for the next place where
russell wilson takes a snap in contrast
to sean watson's plus 250 with the
panthers at plus 300. so the oddsmaker
is much more inclined to think watson is
going to get his wish than wilson will
get his i would make those odds i think
a little bit
longer shorter whatever the right word
is i think it's more likely that wilson
is gone than a minus 1250 proposition
shireen um your what's your gut tell you
is it this year is it next year is it
never for russell wilson getting traded
oh i think he's gone at some point mike
i'm still going to stick with i think he
plays one more year for the seahawks and
if they can't get to the super bowl i
think that's it for russell wilson it's
been too long for them to get to the
super bowl he's ready to go win one they
can't do it this year he's going to
think he has better chances elsewhere
my concern is if they wait a year
they're going to be a lot like the
eagles with carson wentz where it's
going to be harder to conjure leverage
although there will be multiple teams
that will want to get into a bidding war
so it doesn't matter if the seahawks put
a for-sale sign in the yard at that
point because it won't just be the colts
like it was just the colts for
carson wentz this year but but i think a
year from now it'll be more obvious that
the seahawks are ready to move on i
think once you acknowledge it's
inevitable go ahead and move on
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports